[Música]
hola a todos con estas buenas tardes qué
rara me siento de no tener un micrófono
así de mano para poder cantarles
realmente esto es como estar fuera de mi
zona de confort pero me encanta poderles
platicar
algo que yo he vivido y algo de mi
carrera que a lo mejor ustedes no saben
voy a tratar de resumir en 18 minutos
este mi vida artística todo empezó en
este resulta que resulta que yo bueno
soy cantante pero de profesión y por
consecuencia de ser cantante me he
convertido en actriz me he convertido en
productora me he convertido en
y bailarina en la autora en diseñadora
etcétera en muchas cosas a consecuencia
de mi sueño que siempre fue ser cantante
bueno antes les voy a contar el otro
sueño que tuve más descabellado
yo puedo yo puedo es mi frase es mi modo
de vida y lo aprendí desde muy niña yo
vengo de unos padres que son muy
estrictos muy cultos pero también muy
amorosos y muy cariñosos y en la casa
nunca se podía decir no puedo no puedo
típico que todos los niños lloramos y no
puedo cualquier cosita y ellos me
enseñaron que había que cambiar el no
por el yo
a lo mejor podría ser difícil lo que
tenías que hacer pero tenías que
cambiarlo aún yo puedo mi primer yo
puedo fue inconsciente creo yo mis papás
se casaron se conocieron en monterrey
se casaron y mi papá tener una beca para
irse a la universidad de wharton a
estudiar su maestría y su doctorado en
economía gracias a la disidencia nazi y
yo allá en filadelfia pensilvania era un
hospital en el cual hasta se paraban
siamesas en aquella época tenían casos
muy muy complicados yo saqué un pie
primero y estuve en split así con la
pata hasta acá durante unas seis horas
aproximadamente
y fue un caso uno en un millón en
aquella época se llamaba parto
incompleto invertido
normalmente no sobreviven ni la mamá ni
él ni el bebé 1 en cada 10 millones
sobrevive o la mamá o el bebé
en esta ocasión milagrosamente nos
salvamos las dos ese fue mi primer yo
puedo inconsciente totalmente no sabía
pero yo dije yo tengo que salir tengo
que hacer algo
el doctor y mi abuela dijeron esta niña
viene algo grande yo pues no sabía lo
mejor me marcaron desde muy niña pero
también creo que también lo traes en los
genes toda la herencia genética de
guerreros de luchadores de la revolución
de la independencia de mamás feministas
de mamás guerreras de mamás que han
salido adelante de padres muy
trabajadores entonces bueno mi primer
uso de razón fue haber tenido en mis
manos el libro de hans christian
andersen la pequeña sirenita entonces yo
lo leía y era mi obsesión en aquella
época no había tablet nueva y iphone no
había nada entonces yo leía mis libros
todas las noches y mi mamá me preguntó
un día que quiere ser de grande mi
hijita y yo casualmente le dije quiero
ser
ahí está cuando salí de 12 días del
hospital esta incubadora yo nació un 12
de diciembre también eso es otra cosa
causalidad de occidente nací el 12 de
diciembre del día de la virgen de
guadalupe no me pusieron guadalupe
tatiana es mi nombre real y ahí estoy
como con ojos de extraterrestre
muy grandes hay este libro el primer
libro que leí en inglés porque vivíamos
en filadelfia había que hablar inglés
entonces del dinero de mermaid y
entonces mi madre me dijo quieres ser
sirena de grande no se puede y yo como
que no se puede todo se puede
yo puedo ustedes me enseñaron yo puedo
entonces en todas las vacaciones yo
nadaba con las piernas cerradas así
y nada va y nada va aprendí a aguantar
la respiración como un minuto y diez
segundos más o menos abría los ojos
abajo del mar yo sentía que era una
sirena y por más que volteaba nunca
salieron las escamas entonces mi mamá un
día me preguntó y mi papá porque quiere
ser sirena tanto que es lo que te llama
la atención y yo es que cantan todo el
día y nadan mucho
ah pues puedes cantar y puedes nadar
pero sirena no vas a poder ser
ya pues algún día lo voy a lograr algún
día estaba chiquitita bueno entonces
dije voy a ser cantante
claro que sí voy a ser cantante y
afortunadamente mis padres me dieron las
herramientas necesarias me metieron a
clases de piano me metieron a clases de
gimnasia olímpica durante 10 años llegué
a los juegos nacionales y carne primer
lugar o largaron en gimnasia todo eso
era una preparación que yo no sabía para
cuando tuviera la oportunidad de hacer
mi primera audición estudié piano
estudia guitarra salía en la televisión
local en monterrey
y estaba en el equipo estatal de nuevo
león de la cual mi mamá era la
entrenadora mi hermano fue tres veces
campeón nacional de gimnasia olímpica yo
nada más una
de moda
entonces mi hermano que entraba a todos
los concursos habidos y por haber
entró a juguemos a cantar yo era la que
quería entrar pero me pasaba un año de
la edad tenía 13 mi hermano tenía 12 y
dijo yo le entro ganó el mejor
intérprete y yo era su bailarina ahí no
tenemos palito pero soy esta de aquí
las demás son mis primas claro y el
padre para dure toda la vida en balde
había que demostrar que uno podía
entonces yo me alegraba mucho por la
querré de mi hermano y mi hermano tenía
muy en claro que él nada más quería
jugar a cantar que él iba a seguir
siendo estudiante economista conductor
de televisión y todo pero no iba a hacer
esto de su profesión y yo era la que yo
quería que esta era mi profesión ser
cantante entonces pasaron muchos años me
fui de colada también con él a la
audición de vaselina aquella primera
vaselina con con timbiriche y quedé en
la audición juli se estaba haciendo las
audiciones junto con más maestros quedé
en la audición pero me dijo sabes que te
ves muy grande
tenía 14 y me apunto de cumplir 15 pero
pues ya estaba así
entonces me dijo es que esta obra es
como para niños y puesto ya te ves
grandecita desarrollada pero quédate y
mañana va a ver la última audición de la
ópera rock mexicana que se llama cumaná
ok coman que es la historia de tarzán y
jane en rock and roll in heavy metal con
cristal y acero y va a estar bien padre
ok bueno pues yo esté convenciendo a mis
papás por favor déjame quedarme déjame
quedarme la audición déjame quedarme era
un domingo este fui a audicionar y toda
esta preparación que tuve antes me
sirvió
para hacer la audición si me hubiera
quedado en el árbol 3 con nada de líneas
no me hubiera importado pero me quedé
con el papel protagónico femenino de cvm
and es obra de teatro que fue un suceso
dure seis meses en esa obra de teatro
porque de pronto llegó el director de
una compañía disquera y vio la obra con
sus hijos normal un domingo me mandó una
tarjeta que si yo quería hacer una
audición para para lanzarme como
cantante y yo mamá es mi sueño está la
vida ser cantante bueno lo cambie el de
sirena por cercando
no nunca se me juntaron las piernas
entonces bueno fui a hacer la audición
con mi guitarrista cante me quedo en esa
audición y fue a partir de ahí en 1984
después de kumán después de haber sido
rostro del heraldo del 84 me fui a
grabar españa' mi primer disco ahí está
se titulaba tatiana desde el primer
disco dije yo quiero cantar no solo por
cantar
quiero dar mensajes
como soy yo quiero dar mensajes
positivos quiero dar mensajes decir algo
en las canciones no nada más así
entretener entonces entre mi mamá y yo
pues convencemos al productor ya los
compositores de que hay es que esa
canción está pues muy subida de tono
mira que la niña que no lo ha sentido
todavía eso
desde verdad yo tenía 15 años de
monterrey en el df nos decían muchas y
pueblerinas web líneas y nosotros
decíamos a mucha honra gracia
si eso nos salvó de muchas muchas de
muchos peligros
entonces grave es el primer disco y
había canciones como todo tu sin límites
amame no olvides que aún no es tiempo
para amarnos con los cinco sentidos y a
plena luz la canción decía ahora es
tiempo para amarnos con los cinco
centros y mi mamá decía es que la niña
está nerviosa porque pues no cómo va a
cantar eso y de ambas con cambiarle eso
aún no es tiempo para amarnos fue algo
que la gente me creyó porque yo me lo
creía a partir de ahí me invitaron a
hacer películas con mi compadre ahora
pedro fernández y c2
luego hacía giras con luís miguel hacía
giras con lucero hacía giras con juan
gabriel con joan sebastian con lola la
grande bueno con todos los grandes con
lupita d'alessio con todos los
ochenteros con talento de aquella época
y yo era como la mascotita no yo tenía
15 y ahí anda me siempre en domingo
ellos y yo yo baile y yo canto y esto es
mi sueño entonces me daban el micrófono
pero no había inalámbrico entonces
cantabas y de repente el cable se te
quedaba sin duda se te acababa el cable
y daban la vuelta así
la coreografía
enredados por todos lados entonces bueno
pues a raíz de esas canciones con un
mensaje positivo me hablan de la johns
hopkins university de baltimore para
dirigir dos canciones a dueto con johnny
lozada y eran unas campañas
importantísimas de labor social para
latinoamérica que eran a favor de la
paternidad responsable las canciones
fueron un éxito y fueron cantadas de
jóvenes para jóvenes nos dieron premio
en washington en la casa blanca- nos
dieron premio en nueva york' nos dieron
muchos premios y yo me dediqué a hablar
con los jóvenes también no nada más solo
a cantar las canciones sino a informarme
y hablar con los jóvenes que tenían que
ser adultos responsables antes de ser
papás ojalá que la campaña volviera a
ponerse verdad porque hace falta sigue
haciendo falta
lamentablemente entonces de pronto nace
mi primera hija yo engordo 30 kilos
casual conmigo unos 55 de tamaño ya se
imaginará
y de pronto pues estaba entre un
contrato y otro de disqueras de pop yo
seguía cantando porque se viene cantando
rock seguía cantando baladas y de pronto
me dan mi carta de retiro como decía
hace rato al existe
y / que firmó con otra izquierda que no
sabía cuál
dije qué hago qué hago no me por estar
quieta mi carrera es mi sueño ser
cantante tengo que seguir en esto y
voltea a ver a mi hija y me voy
a las tiendas de discos
y yo me acuerdo de esas rondas
infantiles con las que yo jugaba en el
patio del colegio y jugaba en el recreo
y el patio mi casa y la víbora de la mar
y mi tía me cantaba ping pong esté donde
están esas canciones nunca los encontré
grabadas los dije pues yo las voy a
grabar post porque no con muy poco
presupuesto grabé esas canciones pero
dije les voy a dar un giro moderno un
giro a los niños de ahora qué es lo que
están escuchando en ese momento pues
estaban escuchando nada parecía sijena y
estaban escuchando este cargo de todo
merengue salsa hip hop reggae y así es
como dice ese disco ping pong luisen
dance según yo lo iban a tocar en las
discotecas la víbora de la mar también
la víbora de la mar
[Aplausos]
y empecé a grabar todas estas rondas que
estaban olvidadas este escondidas en un
en un cajón o en ritmos actuales fue
tanto el éxito que pues no me la creía
pero antes de tener el éxito pues yo
buscaba donde promocionar estas estas
canciones antes de tener en la portada
del primer disco y yo dije que me voy a
poner toda la vida había diseñado mi
vestuario desde el primer disco el verde
que vieron así de 15 años era ropa
fosforescente 80 era padrísima luego se
me ocurrieron las bolitas todo era de
bolitas luego las claves de sol luego
las rayitas de todo ahora con los niños
dije que voy a hacer que me voy a poner
dije algo que me recuerda mi infancia mi
personaje favorito es wonder woman tan
tan tan tan la mujer maravilla sí claro
o muñequeras que paran las baladas el
lazo de la verdad y entonces fusione la
mujer maravilla con las hadas madrinas
de las caricaturas y de las películas de
princesas y se me ocurrió hacer este
vestuario que que ya lo han visto y que
es un corte con una
y además ahora lo renové y tengo una
corona y tengo este pulseras y guantes
pero básicamente es lo que yo diseñé que
es un corset con estrellas por todos
lados que siempre me han gustado y que
además para mí me dan buena suerte las
estrellas entonces ahí está ese
personaje no me permitían presentarlo a
ningún lado porque como tatiana viene
del pop y del rock y de cantar
tecnificación del tri y como ahora va a
cantar para niños y en esa época veían
lo infantil como chafa como que lo de
meditaba como que lo veían así muy muy
muy sin calidad yo me di a la tarea de
hacer las cosas con calidad como ya
traía una infraestructura de haber hecho
una carrera de cantante pop 10 años dije
lo mismo se los voy a llevar a los niños
rayo láser explosiones luces
computarizadas vídeos escenografía
etcétera pero no había donde presentarlo
entonces voy a un programa de televisión
en el día del niño todavía no tenía
chamba de niños y canto ping pong
llega una llamada y la señora me dice
por favor que me marque tatiana es que
acaba de ocurrir un milagro en mi casa
cuando llego a mi casa le marco yo había
pedido una señal adiós la verdad y le
había dicho por favor dime si voy por
buen camino o ya este disco lo guardó en
un cajón se lo doy a mi hija del legado
musical y ya
y me sigo cantando pop y rock y donde
pueda
había pedido esa señal le habló a la
señora y me dice es la portada del
primer disco infantil en 1995 me dice la
señora acaba de suceder un milagro tengo
una hija con autismo profundo se llama
help y angélica tiene 9 años la niña no
se ha desarrollado y no ha crecido
porque no camina porque no se mueve
porque no reacciona a ningún sonido
incluso el neurólogo piensa que tiene
que es sordomuda
pero acaba de pasar algo y se suelta
lloré y lloré la señora y yo qué pasó
ponemos frente a la tele mientras
tenemos comida familiar y de pronto
escuchamos una voz que no sabíamos de
quién era y la niña empezó a cantar ping
pong es un muñeco muy articulado parada
bailando imitando me frente a la
televisión ahí todavía
nos pusimos a llorar y yo dije si no se
vende un disco si no vende un show si no
pasa nada con esto con esto ya estoy más
que servida estoy emocionada y sigo
pensando que esta es mi misión cantar
por no sólo entretener sino cantar dando
mensajes positivos ayudando sirviendo
conviviendo haciendo visitas hospitales
haciendo labor social
a esta niña después en sus 15 años le
llevé a ping pong de chambelán
y estaba fascinada eliges que a la
señora le decía es que por pimpón tu
hija está así y aparte fue campeona de
natación de la escuela especial aprendió
a leer aprendió a escribir y con
contacto con el mundo el autismo sigue
obviamente pero la niña ya hace contacto
con el mundo gracias a la música la
música mueve emociones la música produce
acciones y la música puede cambiar al
mundo definitivamente lo tengo más que
comprobado esta es mi hija a la cual le
dejé ese legado de música ahorita iba a
cumplir 25 años ha pasado muy rápido el
tiempo después de eso empecé a tener
éxito en shows en arenas en estadios en
lugares muy grandes no me lo esperaba
empecé a tener merchandising que
mochilas y que pero la gente se acercaba
así de oye queremos el vestido igual
este donde lo hacemos pues no tengo yo
te lo hago y te doy regalías a pues anda
le va y así empezó y de pronto me llama
disney y me dicen queremos que hagas el
doblaje
la película hércules ya tenemos el
hércules que va a ser ricky martin y
queremos que tú seas la novia de ricky
martin que es negar a los cielos wow
a ricky yo lo conocía desde que empezó
su carrera desde que entró a menudo era
un chiquitito de 13 años y yo lo conocía
desde entonces pero él ya se había
convertido en una estrella a nivel
mundial
y hago megara y fue algo insólito que
hasta la fecha después de 21 años me
sigue manteniendo ahí vigente con ahora
todos esos niños que ya son adultos y
que crecieron y que están aquí gracias
gracias por estar aquí
[Aplausos]
me dieron mi estrella en el paseo de la
fama de las vegas no lo podía creer
tampoco cada que voy llegó con un
trapito y lo limpio y todo así que este
pedacito es mío
tome la foto muy emocionada y que creen
poder realizar mi sueño de ser sirena
claro que sí lo logré
yo mamá mamá mira si pude entonces toda
esta preparación de haber contenido la
respiración de haber nadado con las
piernas cerradas de haber abierto los
ojos en el mar me sirvió para cuando me
invitaron a hacer la telenovela a mí la
niña de la mochila azul junto a danna
paola en el 2003 4 no me acuerdo y fue
mi sueño hecho realidad tan sueño hecho
realidad que yo me sentía sirena se me
olvidaba que tenía que salir a respirar
entonces por poco me ahogo en esa
telenovela
se me empezó a llenar la cola de agua la
de la sirena
bueno las dos
en el cenote donde filmamos estaba
congelado y después filme en un tanque
congelado medio hipotermia porque no la
vio morado toda morada a ella pero ella
es la de las sirenas
y profesional y yo puedo claro que si
luego me dio parálisis facial por culpa
de esa hipotermia pero saben que todo
valió la pena porque los sueños si se
hacen realidad y hay que decir yo puedo
y de verdad los invito a que cambian el
no por el yo va a ser complicado al
principio pero es un ejercicio mental y
es un ejercicio de decirlo y convencerte
a ti misma y si se pueden hacer los
sueños realidad por más descabellados
que parezcan solamente hay que seguirse
moviendo y no estancarse y le doy
gracias a dios por hacerme su
instrumento de verdad para llevar un
poco de alegría con mi música con mi
presencia con lo que pueda hacer y los
invito también a que no se estacionen
siempre hay que seguir el movimiento
porque yo puedo gracias
[Música]